[Musique]
des collégiens et des enseignants tous
fière d'arborer le drapeau signe de leur
engagement pour la troisième année
consécutive le collège de cambuston est
labellisé eco collège pour 7,7 et qu'au
collège à cette labellisation dans
démarche de développement durable
cette labellisation nationale et
internationale à travers différents
projets autour de la biodiversité avec
en 2014-2015 mon ami la pomme l'année
dernière avec la biodiversité dans le
cadre du fleurissement et là cette année
nous recevons de nouveau la
labellisation autour de thèmes de l'eau
donc nous avons travaillé autour de la
cua pony de mur végétal également avec
tout un travail scénique autour de l'eau
pendant une année les collégiens vont
développer des projets pédagogiques sur
la thématique de l'eau comme cette
culture de légumes basé sur le principe
de la cua pony sistema cap aunis qui va
en fait quelque part utiliser les
déchets des poissons peuvent servir en
fait dans créé pour les plantes et c'est
un projet que vous avez travaillé avec
les élèves un projet pédagogique donc on
travaille t elle puisque là dedans il ya
divers matière il ya la physique et la
mécanique de l'eau et yahia ben la
biochimie donc toutes les matières
peuvent s'investir dans ce genre de
système dans ce collège a été créé le
jardin des poètes un espace végétalisé
par des plantes endémiques
ici les élèves peuvent échanger partager
leurs rêves mais aussi suivre des cours
en plein air et laisser place à la
pratique
on a pu mesurer donc la température
l'humidité les clairement au niveau du
jardin qu'on a comparé avec un autre
environnement du collège et en fait on a
regardé aussi on a listé les êtres
vivants présents et du coup on a pu
comparer la répartition des êtres
vivants
cette journée consacrée au développement
durable a accueilli différents ateliers
dont un basé sur la récupération
comment donner une seconde vie à des
objets
ne fonctionne plus on a démonté un
ordinateur on a remplacé fusible et on a
remonté et nettoyez bien qu'il faut pas
toujours jeter des trucs sur le brunch
va et on qu'on peut redonner une vallée
à la réunion une vingtaine
d'établissements et labellisé eco
collège une démarche soutenue par la
collectivité qui récompense cette
labellisation
[Musique]